[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Hi.
And welcome to episode number
54 of the weekly Google Cloud
Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc Campoy.
And I'm here with my
colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: Hi.
I'm doing pretty well.
How are you doing, Francesc?
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: Pretty good.
Pretty good.
A very busy day with lots of
podcasting, actually, today,
But very excited about having,
actually, someone completely
new.
He's a "newgler"
I'm going to say.
He's been working at
Google for two weeks,
but actually, mostly
like two days.
And he just joined
after Google acquired--
MARK MANDEL: Apigee.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Apigee.
That's the name.
I totally forgot the name.
So we're going to be
talking about what is an API
and what is the API lifecycle.
And it's a very
interesting conversation.
He's been doing this
for quite a while,
so he has a lot of
insights on what you
should be looking at when you
expose your API to the world.
MARK MANDEL: And it's
more than you might think.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: Oh, yeah.
There's a lot of things.
MARK MANDEL: There's
a lot of stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Yeah, and it's not just like,
oh, you should just use
HTTPS-- which you should.
It's way more than that.
So a very interesting
conversation.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And after that, we
have a little extension
from the conversation we had
with Aja last week, talking
a little bit more about Ruby,
talking about how you can
interact with, say, Google
Cloud Services, but with an API
and a set of
libraries that allow
you to not have vendor lock-in.
So you could move it to
another cloud provider
if you so desired.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Yeah, very interesting.
Actually, it makes me wish we
had something like that for Go.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
I wonder if there is.
We should take it up.
MARK MANDEL: We should.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: But before we
get into all of
those topics, we have
a cool thing of the week, which
is brought by yourself, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: It is.
It's brought by me.
Yeah.
Yes, I brought it
by reading blogs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: Good job.
MARK MANDEL: It's
that kind of day.
So recently on the
Kubernetes blog,
there is a really cool
tool called Kompose.
That was a great alliteration.
Kompose with a K.
So if anyone who
has worked with Docker
before-- quite often, people,
they start working with Docker.
And that's cool
and that's great.
And then they often
go to Docker-compose
when they have
multiple containers
they want to work with and
have them work together.
And a question I see quite
often in the community
is, oh, I've got
this Compose thing,
but then I want to
go to Kubernetes.
And I know about Compose, but
I don't know about Kubernetes.
What do I do?
I don't know.
And so this is actually an
open-source tool that lets you
take Docker-compose as
well as a Docker DAB file,
or a Docker Distributed
Application Bundle,
and then you can convert it
into Kubernetes deployments
and services using
this command line tool,
either to push it
directly up to--
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Kubernetes Master?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Or actually just create
the files themselves.
And then you can edit
them as you see fit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Cool.
That is pretty nice.
So basically it is
like a one-off thing.
Like you have a big
Compose file that you
spend a lot of time building.
And rather than having
two of them manually,
just use that, and boom, done.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
then you're good to go.
I think it's a really
nice little way
of learning about containers
and extending them further
into different things.
And then also, like if you're
doing a compare and contrast
against Swarm versus
like Kubernetes,
it's an easy way to bounce
between them both as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
That is very cool.
Cool.
So I think it's time to go talk
with our new coworker, Alan Ho.
MARK MANDEL: Let's go to that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: So
I'm very happy to welcome
Alan Ho to the podcast.
Hi, Alan.
How are you doing?
ALAN HO: I'm doing well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: So I'm
very excited because you're
actually the first person
that we interviewed
that comes from Apigee.
You were a lead developer
for advocacy for Apigee?
ALAN HO: That's right.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Could
you tell us a little bit more
about what you do?
ALAN HO: So my main job is to
help our customers essentially
build better APIs.
So I do a lot of-- I
work with developers.
I also work with not
just developers, but also
architects to build
their API programs
and help build better APIs.
I give them some
tips and consulting.
I help them with the product.
And I give a lot of
feedback to our own product
team about the usage of Apigee.
MARK MANDEL: And I believe this
is your second day at Google,
is that right?
ALAN HO: Well, technically, this
is my second week at Google.
So we on-boarded last
Wednesday, but I was out
at an API conference last week,
right after we on-boarded,
in Chicago.
So second day in
the Venice office.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Nice.
Being Venice, the one in Los
Angeles, not Venice, Italy?
ALAN HO: No.
The one in Los Angeles.
You're right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Oh, it's less fancy.
It's still pretty cool, though.
Nice.
So we've said the
word API-- well,
the letters API-- many,
many times already.
Why don't you give us your
definition of what an API is.
ALAN HO: Yeah.
Well, an API is an Application
Programming Interface.
But today, I mean, there's
a lot of application.
I mean, we've been
having APIs forever,
but today, when we say APIs,
we usually specifically
refer to web APIs, web
APIs hosted in the cloud
or within your own data center.
And so I think there's
nothing-- APIs,
probably the better question
to ask is not what is an API?
But rather, what makes a
good API versus a bad API?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Then answer that question.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
what does make
a great API versus a bad API?
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: We're totally
happy with that
different question, too.
ALAN HO: Yeah, I think
the primary difference
is kind of your mindset.
And so there's the mindset for
a lot of developers when they
create APIs, they
think about just
exposing their interface,
their application
through a HTTP interface.
That's one way to
think about it.
But good APIs think
more about the consumer.
They think about it
as, what's the easiest
way that a consumer can derive
value from the application
I built?
And when I say the
easiest way, that
means there's a lot of things
that are necessary to happen.
It's not just throw
on an interface
and have a PDF to let
you code against it,
but there's a lot
of different steps
you need to take
for building an API.
But I want to turn it around.
Like how does a GCP
think about APIs?
What makes a good API
from a GCP standpoint?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
That's a very good question.
I'd say that it's something that
empowers our customers to do
whatever they need in the
easiest and most efficient way.
I think that that is
maybe a decent definition.
I don't know.
What do you think, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: I think you gave
a very good answer, Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: OK.
And that was not even prepared.
I just nailed that.
Yeah, so I think that
what you were pointing out
is it is not just
about giving a way
to access our services,
because otherwise,
doing phone calls could
be also an API somehow.
ALAN HO: That's right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
It is really making
it as efficient as possible.
MARK MANDEL: I think they
should bring back fax machines.
I think that's what
I'm waiting for.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
That's definitely a good idea.
MARK MANDEL: That's how
I'm going to build my API
interfaces from now on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: So now that we
have kind of a good
definition, an idea
of what a good API is,
let's talk about why.
Why would a company
create an API?
ALAN HO: There's actually
multiple, I would say,
stages of value that a
company can create in API.
I mean, so the first
reason is a lot
of companies are now building
their software, actually,
as micro services.
And all micro services
communicate via API.
So any company that is
building a micro service today
is essentially building an API.
That's kind of like the lowest
level of value in my opinion
because it's all
about making sure
that you create these
connected applications
and let teams not
have to work on one
big monolithic application.
So maybe that's
the lowest level.
The second level of
companies who are making APIs
is that they want to expose
their software as a product.
So basically,
especially if you want
to create a developer-- if you
have a core value proposition
and you need to
enable developers
to build on top
of it, they would
be exposed to the product.
And the classic
example is mobile apps.
Today, if you have a mobile
app, it talks through an API.
It's usually not a web page.
And even it is a web page,
it's usually a single-page app.
So they're calling APIs.
MARK MANDEL: So really, you need
APIs so that you could have,
potentially, a variety
of clients or front
ends to be able to access the
information that your business
or your service provides.
Would that be accurate?
ALAN HO: Correct.
Yeah.
It sounds simplistic,
but that is the case.
And I think the
highest form of APIs,
though, is more
building an ecosystem.
For example, Walgreens,
a lot of people
know Walgreens is a place where
they can pick up drugs or print
out pictures.
So what they found is that when
people go pick up a picture,
they end up doing other things
like they buy some chips,
or they might buy a toy, or
do some grocery shopping,
things of that sort.
In fact, they found
people who does something
on the web and mobile and
then come into the store
to do something have
almost a 6x increase
in the amount of revenue that
they spend per store visit.
So it becomes an advantage to
have as much usage of mobile
prior to going into the store.
So what they did is then
they opened up their API
to all these photo apps.
There's tons of
photo apps out there.
And what they let
you do is they allow
people to print
their photos straight
from these photo
apps in the store
and pick it up in the store.
So that way, they drive
a lot of foot traffic
and they have an
ecosystem of applications
that are driving this foot
traffic into the store.
So there's multiple levels of
reasons and business reasons
why you can use APIs.
And it just all matters on
which particular use case
and what drives the
most business value.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Cool.
So as soon as you start
doing things like this,
though, where you are exposing
your API to the world,
there's a bunch of
things that you're
going to need to start handling,
like security, but also
like quotas.
And, I mean, someone is going to
need to pay for those pictures.
How do you manage those things?
ALAN HO: Well, as we talk about
application development life
cycles, in a similar
way, there is
what we call the API lifecycle.
And there are probably
eight major steps
of doing development.
And if you've got questions,
feel free to interrupt me.
And those steps break
down to design, develop,
securing your API,
publishing your API,
scaling it, monitoring it,
analyzing the people who use
the API, and last but not
least, monetizing your API.
And so for each of
these steps, there's
going to be a set of
other tasks to do.
So for example, when you're
first designing your API,
what we recommend
is that you start
sharing the design of your
API with your consumers
as quickly as possible.
One of the very
popular standard is
Swagger, which has now been
re-branded to Open API.
That's a very, very easy way
and a language-agnostic way
to actually understand
whether people like
your API in the first place.
So getting customers to
actually-- having the design,
making sure you have the tools
to circulate that and co-edit
those APIs, almost like
you're editing a Google Doc,
is going to be very,
very important for making
sure your API is consumable.
And then the next
step of that is
that when you're
developing your APIs--
I'm not talking about developing
the application logic,
but your actual APIs--
there's a lot of things
that you also need to do, too.
So for example, if
your back end so
happens to be an old
school SOAP service,
you may want to
create an API with out
of the box-- use some way
to convert SOAP to REST.
And especially if you have
more complicated use cases,
you might actually have to
use JavaScript, or Node,
or something of that sort to
facade your existing backend.
Then the next step of that
would be to secure your API.
So we're talking about
having OAuth, SSL, putting
in some, what I would call,
threat protection for detecting
SQL injection attacks,
things of that sort.
One of the things that people
don't realize with APIs
is that, unlike web pages,
you can leak a lot more data
through an API than a web page.
And a lot of times when
people develop their APIs,
they try to develop their
APIs for as many consumers as
possible.
So they end up returning
lots and lots of information
through the API, which is
a very, very bad practice.
So making sure your
API is stripping out
things that are sensitive,
things that the customer really
doesn't need becomes very
important in security.
And last but not
least, like today we've
got a lot of denial-of-service
bots out there,
or bots that scrape websites.
Bots are now getting
smart to the point
that they can scrape
the APIs themselves.
So being able to detect what
we call low and slow attacks,
and then doing things
like a honeypot
so that you can direct
people to a fake API,
a mock API, instead
of your real data,
becomes really important
from a security standpoint.
MARK MANDEL: So it sounds like
there's a bit of a balancing
act there, too.
Because obviously,
if you've got,
say, an ecosystem
that you're building
and you want people to
come and use your APIs,
you kind of want to expose
it as much as possible.
But on the flip
side, you don't want
to expose anything that may
be sensitive or harmful.
How do you kind of
combat that, or at least
find the right level of
the sweet spot of where
that could be?
ALAN HO: So that's where
what I would actually do
is I would look at the
particular use case.
So you might have an API
that might be used in a B
to B scenario, like a
server calling that API.
Or it might be used
directly by a mobile app.
In those scenarios, what I
would personally recommend
is that you split them
into two different APIs.
The one for the mobile app
might have less information,
and it would be definitely
protected by OAuth.
And then, the one that's meant
to be called from a server,
it might have a different
authentication authorization
mechanism and serve
more data through it.
So my recommendation is that
if you have multiple use
cases that are
very, very different
that serves different
information,
don't try to jam it
all into one API,
but rather, have multiple APIs.
Now, remember, just because
you have multiple APIs
doesn't mean that you can't
still have one implementation.
It just means creating
multiple facades
on the same backend system.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Cool.
There's a question that
I've got a couple of times.
And since you're here, I
wonder if you could answer it,
which is, let's
imagine that you want
to have your API
available to the world
and you have an interest of
as many people as possible
using it, but you
have terms of service.
How do you make sure
that only the people that
have agreed to terms
of services or things
like that-- people that
are not doing something
that you consider as abuse of
your API-- have access to it?
What are the kind of
techniques that you
would recommend for that?
ALAN HO: So I mean, if you
go to most cloud providers,
they basically have different
quota limits for each user.
If you want to expose
this to the world,
the number one thing to do is
create a portal, a developer
portal where people can, in a
self-service way, get API keys.
And when they sign up
for these APIs keys,
you can assign
different quota limits
for each of the--
depending on what service
they're signing up for.
And then within a gateway--
this is the purpose
of why you would want to have a
gateway in front of your APIs.
The gateway would be able to
do counting and making sure
that people don't exceed
their particular limits.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Cool.
So I think I interrupted
you in the middle of the API
lifecycle.
So we were talking about
how to secure an API.
What could be the next step?
ALAN HO: Yeah.
So after you secure
your API, you
would publish it so that
the world can see it.
And publishing an API,
a lot of times people
say, oh, I just need to publish
the API in developer portal
if I have a public API.
Well, the truth is,
even if your API is only
being used within
your own company,
it's probably a good
idea to publish it
so that people within
your own company
are not reinventing the wheel.
It's also really
important to have
some sort of issue developer
keys even within your own org
so that you know who within
the company is using your APIs.
And it allows you to
communicate to those people
when the APIs are going
to change or deprecated.
And last but not least, you need
that for chargebacks as well.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so that
sounds interesting as well.
Now, I don't know a huge amount
of Swagger about Open API,
but does that help
with that process
of being able to communicate
about what's published
and what's not published
and how those things work?
ALAN HO: Yeah, so the
great thing about Swagger
is that after you define your
model and you define your APIs,
you can actually annotate
your Swagger document
and put the documentation
within Swagger itself.
And what it'll do
is that you can
use Swagger editors to
generate the documentation
like live interactive
documentation.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
ALAN HO: So instead of just
having like a PDF file,
you can actually create a
live, testable UI that you
can actually, essentially,
do curl commands
and it would give you
the actual results.
So after publishing, then
the next thing you need to do
is scale your API.
And there's multiples from
a scalability standpoint.
If your API is being called
from many, many clients
around the world,
you need to make sure
that you have almost like
a CDN-- you have points
of presence in many,
many different data
centers all around
the world, especially
as close as possible to
the consuming client.
So Apigee, depending on
what kind of service--
use the on-prime version
or the cloud version--
we're geo-distributed
in lots of data centers.
And we're going to
also be moving on--
and our main one that we
use is Amazon Web Services--
but in the future,
we're obviously
going to be doing Google
Cloud and other cloud platform
providers out there, too.
The other thing, too, is that
from a scaling standpoint,
it's also really
important to remember
that you can put things like
caching in your gateway, which
will reduce a lot
of the API calls
to your very backend systems.
And that could drastically
reduce the costs
that you need to
scale your system.
MARK MANDEL: That makes sense.
ALAN HO: And then, after
you've scaled the system,
the next thing is you've got
to make sure the thing doesn't
fall over.
So having all the dashboards--
application performance
monitoring dashboards
and logging dashboards--
becomes really important.
And one of the
things I tell people
is that, yes, you might
have logging and application
performance monitoring
on your app,
but if you have monitoring
and logging at the application
interface, at the API
layer, it actually gives you
a much better sense of what
the customer is actually
experiencing.
So having monitoring
at that layer,
not at the application layer,
but the programming interface
layer, it helps you
quickly diagnose
whether your customers are
meeting their SLAs, things
of that sort.
Because your application
is somewhat--
it doesn't understand which
particular users are using
that API, nor does it
understand the level of the SLA
that they have
promised the user.
But at the API tier, it
does understand that.
So that's where it
becomes very valuable.
And then two more
steps, just two more.
After you make sure
that your API is stable
and it's meeting its
SLAs, then you've
got to figure out who's
actually using your API.
So when you're
creating these APIs,
it's almost like a funnel.
A lot of times developers
would sign up for the API,
and then maybe
30% or 40% of them
might actually send an API call.
And then, of that,
another maybe 10%
might actually use your
API on a regular basis.
And just understanding those
steps become very important
because as developers
are going down
this, what I call,
developer funnel,
you may want to engage
them in a different way.
So for the people who
have used your API,
there's actually kind of
a magic cut off point.
We found that developers use
your APIs for three weeks,
and maybe not sending
traffic every day,
but they've used your
API for three weeks,
you see that the engagement of
that user and the propensity
for them to buy the
product is way, way higher.
So kind of understanding
who's using your APIs
and targeting them in a right
way becomes really important.
MARK MANDEL: Just
a quick question,
when you say who's
using those APIs,
do you mean specifically
which applications
are using those APIs
or actually which
possible customers
through those applications
are using those APIs?
ALAN HO: Both.
Yeah, so you may want to
see, are iOS applications
using me more or are Android
applications using me more?
You might want to
segment your applications
by the type of app.
But then you might
want to slice and dice
between the types of
companies that are using it.
So is it a startup developer
or is it a large enterprise?
Like a large enterprise,
they're very likely to pay you
a lot more money.
But if it's a startup
developer for a hot startup,
you still may want
to engage them
because they could provide
you a lot of great free press
for your APIs.
So understanding who
is using your API
becomes critically
important for learning
how to engage those customers.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Cool.
So I think you mentioned
there was a one last.
ALAN HO: Yeah, one last one
is you've got to make money.
MARK MANDEL: Profit!
ALAN HO: Right, profit.
Exactly!
So being able to
charge people's credit
cards for-- the simple way of
thinking about monetization
is the Amazon Web Services way.
You charge per API call.
But the reality is, when
you talk about these API
ecosystems, for
example, Walgreens,
they don't charge for their API
at all because they want people
to use their API so that more
people come into the store
and spend more money.
So instead, they might have
internal charge-back mechanisms
to charge other business
divisions whenever
their APIs are being used.
So when you think
about monetization,
you need to think about directly
monetizing it, indirectly
monetizing it, or
internal charge-backs
within your organization.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
ALAN HO: So, yeah,
that's the life cycle.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: So that seems
like there's a lot of
things that you should
take into account
whenever you are going
to publish an API, which I guess
that's the reason why Apigee
exists at all.
So I was wondering
if you could give us
a pretty high view of how does
it look to go through this API
lifecycle using Apigee?
ALAN HO: Yeah.
So Apigee is an API management
platform that-- I mean,
our goal is to make
it very fast for you
to get through this lifecycle.
Because I just rattled off
a ton of steps, but the way
that we do it is that
we provide design tools.
So we have a Swagger editor--
it's a Swagger/Open API
editor that we've contributed
from an open-source standpoint,
but we also have it
built into our product.
So we encourage people to
create their API design,
then load their APIs,
then proxy their APIs
through Apigee's gateway.
And that provides
you the ability
to add security, monitoring,
analysis on top of it.
And then we allow people to
publish developer portals
in a turnkey fashion
so that you don't
have to mess around with
Drupal or your own CMS system.
And then we have out-of-box
connectors for monetization.
So whether it's payment
providers, things of that sort,
we just accelerate
it and we provide
all the connectors for you
to make it stand up your API
program as quickly as possible.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
I think we'll
definitely get you back
to do a more in-depth analysis
of exactly what Apigee
can do in the API space.
But since we are running out
of time, some final questions.
I wanted to ask, what's the
coolest or your favorite?
What's the most
interesting API you've
come across in all your
time working with APIs?
ALAN HO: Oh.
What's the coolest API?
I would say, very
recently, the Uber APIs
are the most interesting.
The Uber API--
Uber provides APIs
so that you can call
a cab from anywhere.
And this allows you to-- they
actually do multiple things.
They allow you to call.
They have an API to pick
up anybody or anything
and deliver it to
somewhere else.
And that drastically
changes how local commerce
is done because when
you create a store
and things of that sort,
there's an automatic assumption
of how-- you create
stores based on how far it
takes to drive there or
the reach of the store.
And suddenly, when
you have an API that
lets you deliver almost
anything to anywhere
within a city in
less than 30 minutes,
you drastically change how
stores should be thought about
and how you can
connect with customers.
And they also have
a cool API, too,
that even if you're in an
Uber and going to the store,
you can monitor what every
single person is doing.
And then, assuming the user
gives permission, and even
let them know about products
that you're about to see
or before you get
into the store itself.
So they've created this
end-to-end trip experience,
which is really going to
change how people build apps
as well as how people
actually-- potentially
how cities can be arranged for
shopping as well as living.
So I think that is probably
the most game-changing API
that I've worked with so far.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Cool.
ALAN HO: And you can
go on Apigee blog.
I had a webcast with
their Chris Messina,
the guy who used
to work at Google
and invented the hashtag.
And he goes through all
those cool use cases.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Cool.
We'll have a link to that
on the show notes as usual.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
All right.
Before we finish up, is
there anything interesting
or anything we haven't
managed to cover
that you want to talk about
before we wrap things up here?
ALAN HO: Make APIs great again.
Just joking.
No, that it builds great APIs.
If you have any questions, I'm
always available via Twitter.
And we'll also have
some show notes.
And get a hold of me.
Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Cool.
We'll have a link to your
Twitter from the show notes
if anyone wants to contact you.
Great.
Thank you so much.
ALAN HO: Take care.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks.
Thanks again to Alan
for joining us today.
A very interesting
conversation, more at a higher
level about APIs, but I think
that's really, really good
and really interesting.
Just a lot of things
to consider and talk
about when building APIs for
services and people to use.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: Yeah, I think
that this is going to be a good
reference episode that we may
be able to use as a table
of contents of topics
to go over in more depth.
Because every
single one of those
steps he mentioned in the
API lifecycle, I think,
deserve an episode.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
They could definitely
be their own episode.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
So it's going to be fun.
Great.
So let's go with the
question of the week.
And the question of the week
today comes not from Aja,
but the answer comes from Aja.
And the question is,
OK, so let's imagine
that I'm building
this application
and I want to use
some cloud provider.
So let's say that I'm currently
using storage, so S3 on Amazon.
And I'm considering
moving to Google Cloud
Storage at some point.
Is there any way that
I can write my code
against an API or
a library that will
abstract the detail of
what is the cloud provider?
So then, to my question,
would it be easier?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so I
think this is really cool.
So actually, Aja, who was
on the episode last week,
does a Cloud Minute video
on covering exactly this,
with storage specifically.
But there's a great
Ruby library called
Fog that literally does exactly
what you're talking about.
It acts as an abstraction to a
variety, quite a wide variety
of cloud providers, through
compute, DNS storage,
and several other
services that are
commonly available
across cloud providers.
And what makes this
really, really powerful is,
yeah, I could be running on,
say, AWS interacting with S3.
I work against the API.
And then if I want
to be like, oh,
let's see how this works
on Google Cloud storage--
maybe it's better.
Maybe it's worse.
Let's find out--
all I need to do
is basically change my provider
with my authentication details,
credentials, et cetera.
And then I'm good to go.
I don't have to change my code.
I can just push stuff up
into Google Cloud storage
or whatever it is
I'm working with.
And then I can keep on
moving on from there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
It is very cool.
I was checking now the list
of providers they have.
And it is more than all
the cloud providers I know.
It's crazy.
There was like 30 of them.
It is pretty amazing.
So whatever it is that you
might be considering using,
I think it's a
good idea if you're
writing Ruby to go
check it out and have
an idea of what kind of APIs you
could use across any provider.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Cool.
So Francesc, thanks again
for hanging out with me.
Are you doing anything special?
I know we have our team
off-site coming up.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
So currently, if
everything went fine,
by the time this
episode is out, I'm
currently hanging
out in Shanghai.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yup.
So I'm pretty excited about
that-- holidays, basically.
And after that, back
to the United States
to have an off-site with the
whole team in Los Angeles.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: So
I guess I'll see you there?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah.
I will be there.
That's where I will be next
week-- or the week after that,
I should say, as well.
I'm just going to be
kind of hanging out
around San Francisco.
Things are winding down
for the rest of the year.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Cool.
And then get ready
for next year,
where I'm actually--
just to give
a very short list of places
I'm going to be-- I will
be at GoLab IO in Florence.
Then I'll go to
FOSDEM in Brussels.
Then I go to GopherCon India.
And I think that that's is
for now-- and after February.
So yeah.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty good.
All I'm really concerned
about is Next and GDC.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Oh,
yes, that's in February.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: OK.
That's going to be fun.
So, yeah, busy, busy year
next year, but for now,
for this year, pretty calm.
I'm very excited
about not doing much.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, like I said before, thank
you so much for joining me
for yet another week.
Have a wonderful trip.
And we'll see you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: Thank you.
And, yeah, see
you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]